[Music]
I am Dr nandor fodorp the world's
foremost parapsychologist I am not a
skeptic this is the strangest case I
have ever enthaled a family living in
Farmhouse claim a talking Mongoose lives
in their Barn creature's name is Jeff
[Music]
talking Mongoose the urban family are
peculiar Did You observe this creature
no no I did hear it we are going to the
Isle of Man I have almost 20 years of
research in this field
your SSA Jeff is the creature here well
because we can't see him doesn't mean he
ain't here I see
[Music]
skepticism indeed
this is an inexplicable Force you say
the way Rascal is probably watching us
right now everybody on this island has
their Jeff story tell me yours you and I
both know Rhino Jab
[Music]
can you tell him to come out so we can
see him
is that him there what is the Irving's
motive let's strike me as con artists
we're here with our eyes as much as we
do Aries these people are lying I think
he exists I'm certain of it
you show yourself I mean you no harm
please
show me that you're real
hold on here's a call for you it is from
him
hello
[Music]
[Applause]